R
RESPONDED.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> HAVE YOU READ SENATOR
GRASSLEY'S AND MY REPORT ON
HUNTER BIDEN'S CORRUPTION ISSUED
IN SEPTEMBER OF 2020 AND
NOVEMBER OF 2020.
HAVE YOU READ THOSE REPORTS?
>> I HAVE HAD A CHANCE TO LOOK
AT IT.
>> DO YOU SEE ANY SIGN OF
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION IN THOSE
REPORTS?
>> THAT WOULD BE A HARD QUESTION
FOR ME TO ANSWER.
>> NO, IT'S VERY EASY.
IT'S VERY EASY TO ANSWER.
THERE'S NO RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
THAT REPORT IS COMPLETELY CLEAN
OF ANY INTERFERENCE OF FOREIGN
INFLUENCE.
ALL THOUGH WE HAVE BEEN FALSELY
ACCUSED INCLUDING BY THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE OF
SPREADING RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
>> Sean: ASK YOURSELF, WHY IS
CHRIS WRAY SO UNWILLING TO BE
HONEST ABOUT WHAT IS SO OBVIOUS
TO EVERYBODY ELSE THAT IN FACT
THE HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP HAD ZERO
TO DO WITH RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
IT IS LONG PAST DUE FOR WRAY TO
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE ROT
INSIDE THE FBI LEADERSHIP.
RECENTLY REELECTED SENATOR FROM
WISCONSIN, RON JOHNSON.
FIRST, LET ME CONGRATULATE YOU
AND YOU WERE ACCURATE WITH THE
AUDIENCE SAYING YOU HAD A TOUGH
RACE.
YOU HAD ABOUT $100 MILLION IN
ASSETS DUMPED ON YOUR HANDS AND
YOUR WORK IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT.
LET ME ASK THIS, THERE'S GOING
TO BE AS MANY AS 20+ FBI WHISTLE
BLOWERS AND THEY'RE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT HOW THE FBI HAS BEEN
POLITICIZED AND WE NOW KNOW IN
OCTOBER OF 2016, THEY OFFERED
CHRISTOPHER STEELE $1 MILLION IF
HE COULD CORROBORATE THE DOSSIER
AND THE BULK OF THE INFORMATION
AND THEY SAID THAT IN FACT THEY
HAD AFFIRM IT HAD TO BE TRUE
THAT THEY VERIFIED IT.
WHAT IS GOING ON INSIDE THE FBI?
HOW DEEP IS THIS POLITICAL BIAS
WITHIN THE FBI?
>> SEAN, DIRECTOR WRAY WAS
DIRECTOR IN 2017 AND UNDER HIS
WATCH THE INTEL COMMITTEE SAID
THE STEELE DOSSIER WAS TAINTED
WITH RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
UNDER HIS WATCH, THE FBI
OBTAINED HUNTEDDER BIDEN'S
LAP -- HUNTER BIDEN'S LAPTOP IN
2017 AND DID NOTHING WITH IT.
UNDER HIS WATCH ACCORDING TO
WHISTLE BLOWERS, THEY DEVELOP
ADD SCHEME IN AUGUST OF 2020 TO
DOWN PLAY THE DEROGATORY
INFORMATION TO DEEP 60
INVESTIGATION.
UNDER HIS WATCH AND THAT SAME
MONTH, THEY PROVIDED AN UNSO
LISTED BRIEFING TO SENATOR
GRASSLEY AND MYSELF AND IT WAS A
NOTHING BRIEFING.
I KNEW IT WAS A SET UP AND IT
WAS A SET UP BECAUSE NINE MONTHS
LATER AND LEAKED IT TO THE
WASHINGTON POST TO SMEAR ME AND
THEREFORE INTERFERE IN THE 2022
WISCONSIN U.S. SENATE ELECTION.
THEY INTERFERED IN THE U.S. 2020
ELECTION.
HIS PRIMARY JOB AS NEW DIRECTOR
WAS TO CLEAN UP AND RESTORE
INTEGRITY AND CREDIBILITY IN THE
FBI AND FAILED MISERABLY AND I
DON'T BELIEVE A WORD HE SAYS AND
THAT'S UNFORTUNATE.
>> Sean: WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
THE FBI, WE KNOW FOR EXAMPLE IF
THEY USE AN UNVERIFIABLE DOSSIER
THAT HILLARY CLINTON PAID FOR
AND THEY SAY IT'S VERIFIED AND
THEY SAY TO A WARRANT AND IS THE
FBI POLITICIZED ON THE ISSUE OF
HUNTER BIDEN'S LAPTOP AND THE
ISSUE OF PARENTS SPEAKING OUT AT
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS AND
INVESTIGATING THEM AS DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS, IS ALL OF THIS NOW
MUCH BIGGER THAN THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THOUGHT AND HOW MANY
WHISTLE BLOWERS ARE WE LIKELY TO
HEAR FROM?
>> I HOPE A WHOLE LOT MORE.
SO PLEASE GO TO
WHISTLEBLOWER@RONJOHNSON.GOV AND
WE NEED TO FIND OUT EXACTLY HOW
POLITICIZED AND PARTISAN THE
FBI.S THIS IS OUT OF CONTROL.
WE HAVE THE CORRUPTION OF THE
BIDEN FAMILY COMPROMISING OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY, BUT WE HAVE
PARTISANSHIP AND THE
POLITICIZATION AND WEAPONIZATION
OF THE FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TOGETHER WITH THE
HEALTH AGENCIES AND WE NEED
WHISTLE BLOWERS IN AMERICAN
PEOPLE DESERVING THE TRUTH.
WHISTLEBLOWERS@RONJOHNSON.GOV.
COME FORWARD AND TELL US THE
TRUT